deutschlands schulen eine zwei klassen
gesellschaft
dieser mann ist verbeamteter lehrer
erdkunde und sport
dieser mann ist angestellter mathelehrer
er muss sozialabgaben zahlen und hat bis
zu 800 euro weniger netto
als der beamte für die exakt gleiche
arbeit als voll gerecht der beamte ist
privatpatient einen teil seiner beträge
übernimmt der steuerzahler
der angestellte ist bei der bahn ja aber
dafür dürfen wir beamten nicht streiten
die dürfen das stimmt aber das lohnplus
dass die angestellten erstreiten kriegen
dann automatisch auch die beamten
wirklich aber vor allem ist der beamte
unkündbar
außer bei schweren dienstvergehen oder
mehr als einem jahr gefängnis dazu das
bayerische kultusministerium zitat
unfähigkeit ist kein dienstvergehen
wissen viele gar nicht aber mallorca ist
die größte stadt italiens
das aufstellen der kahle asten ist der
letzte noch aktive vulkan im sauerland
mädchen sind nachweislich gemahls jungs
das hat zwar nichts mit erdkunde zu tun
aber ich wollte es mal erwähnt haben
einen verbeamteten deutschen studienrat
wirst du nie wieder los nicht in ordnung
wenn ich krank bin
klima sechs wochen kein geld mehr
der war ganz fair solar will leute ich
merke ich krieg schon wieder burnout
lehrer das schlimmste kastenwesen